foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video I'm going
to be doing some ranking based on the
performance of previous ranking Style
videos you guys at least most of you
seem to enjoy them so here's another at
this stage I've ranked a lot of
different types of characters I've
ranked the most powerful slytherins
gryffindors hufflepuffs ravenclaws auras
Death Eaters Dumbledore's Army members
Order of the Phoenix members and more
but what I haven't done yet is rank the
most powerful pure blood Wizards in The
Wizarding World blood status is one of
the most controversial aspects of The
Wizarding World a concept in which
Wizarding families can be distinguished
by the level of magically endowed family
members generally speaking people are
slotted into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood or
muggle we're introduced to quite a few
characters in the Harry Potter story
that come from these pure Bloodlines and
they certainly aren't afraid to remind
us of it Malfoy's however what we must
remember is that at the end of the day
pureblood status it doesn't mean
anything the most powerful purebloods
are not the most powerful Wizards in
fact a top 10 list for the most powerful
Wizards would only include a couple of
the people in this list the majority of
powerful witches and wizards in The
Wizarding World are actually half Bloods
before we get started I want to mention
a couple of things first of all I'm
going to omit the Hogwarts Founders and
the peverals as their sort of op second
of all I'm going to try my best to only
include one person from each Wizarding
family as otherwise the list could get
quite overcrowded with one surname
thirdly I want you to pause the video
and comment your top 10 list down below
before you dive in anyway without
further Ado here is my top 10 list of
the most powerful pure blood Wizards in
The Wizarding World if I miss or forget
a name that is deserving of a spot
please forgive me number 10. Bill
Weasley Bill Weasley was the eldest
Weasley child born as early as 1970. he
attended Hogwarts between 1982 and 1989
and during this time time you became
both a prefect and Head Boy Bill is
considered by many to be the most
powerful of the Weasley children largely
due to his occupation as a curse breaker
one who removes counters or breaks
curses placed on objects the profession
is thought to be extremely challenging
and particularly dangerous requiring a
complex understanding of magic and a
proven ability to perform a broad
spectrum of different spells bill was
highly skilled in aritmancy dueling
Transfiguration conjuration charms spell
creation divination and even the dark
arts bill was truly a powerful wizard
before you say hey Molly was the
strongest Wheezy watch the video a
little longer 9. Frank Longbottom Frank
Longbottom doesn't make it into the
story much and that's because he's
tragically incapacitated during the
first Wizarding War you see Frank and
his wife Alice Longbottom the parents of
Neville Longbottom were both powerful
auras that joined the Order of the
Phoenix and opposed Lord Voldemort
unfortunately for them how however they
were a little too good at their jobs
defying him on three occasions as well
as capturing and imprisoning many of
Voldemort's Death Eaters because of this
they were honed in on and targeted one
day Frank and Alice were attacked with
the cruciatus curse by Bellatrix Barty
Crouch Jr and rodolfus the strange
though the pair didn't die they were
unable to continue normal life and
effectively went insane Frank being
targeted tells me that he was a very
valuable asset for the order and likely
a very powerful wizard who deserves a
spot on this list 8. James Potter James
Potter was a British pure blood wizard
born March 27 1960 to parents Fremont
and euphemia Potter like the other
Marauders James was so skilled in the
subject of transfiguration that he was
able to become an animagus The
Staggering young age of 15. after
successfully achieving this notable
accomplishment he was able to transform
into a stag whenever he wanted in order
to accomplish such a feat it was also
industry that James have sufficient
knowledge of potion making as becoming
an animagus for the first time requires
an animagus potion a highly complicated
potion that requires exceptional
potion-making ability in addition to
Transfiguration and potion making James
was also a talented duelist having
defeated Snape on numerous occasions and
an accomplished practitioner of charms
having helped to create the Marauders
map alongside the other members of the
group 7. Sirius Black Sirius Black The
Godfather of Harry Potter and member of
the black family began studying at
Hogwarts in the year 1971 along with the
other Marauders during his time at
school he was talented the rebellious
young man with a knack for performing
magic while sirius's magical development
was somewhat stunted by the extensive
amount of time that he spent in Azkaban
he still ended up being a supremely
powerful wizard in addition to being a
highly skilled at Transfiguration and
eventually becoming an animagus assuming
the form of a black dog Sirius was also
skilled at dueling Brewing potions
producing germs producing non-verbal
magic and even occlimency 6. Molly
Pruitt Weasley next up we have Molly
Pruitt or as most of you know her Ollie
Weasley that's right Molly hailed from
the powerful pure blood Wizarding family
The Pruitts the Pruitt family produced
many powerful witches and wizards
including Molly's Brothers Gideon and
Fabian who died in the first Wizarding
War while fighting off five Death Eaters
Molly's other most significant
achievement was besting a powerful witch
Bellatrix the strange one of the most
powerful witches in the entire Wizarding
World and one of Lord Voldemort's most
loyal followers she was primarily
portrayed as an unassuming motherly
figure known for her caring and
nurturing manner however during the
Battle of Hogwarts Molly proved that in
times of adversity she's able to tap
into levels of power that will give even
the most powerful witches and wizards a
run for their money she was skilled in
dueling charms healing magic potions
Transfiguration and even the dark arts
5. Horace Slughorn Professor Horace
lokhorn was a British wizard that worked
at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry he was a highly respected and
accomplished man who served as both
potions master and head of Southern
house he was a brilliant man and perhaps
one of the most talented potioneers of
his time slowcorn was a triple threat he
was cunning wise and book smart which
made him an exceptionally powerful man
in fact when the Death Eaters were
returning they tried it time and time
again to recruit slocorn who was rather
modest about his own capabilities what
would the Death Eaters want with the
poor brokered down old buffer like me I
imagined that they would want to turn
your considerable talents to coercion
torture and murder as well as being a
master potioneer slow corn was also a
very talented duelist Transfiguration
expert auckland's charms expert dark
arts practitioner and as it turns out
expert piano player 4. Kingsley
shacklebolt Kingsley shacklebolt was a
British pure blood wizard Order of the
Phoenix member powerful and later
Minister for magic and his youth
shacklebolt attended Hogwarts and formed
particularly well on his nudes
fulfilling all of the necessary
qualifications to become an aura before
eventually becoming Minister for magic
Kingsley was a high-ranking aura despite
a very powerful and balanced arsenal of
magical capabilities shacklebolt's
fellow order members held him in a very
high regard and even Lord Voldemort
himself considered kingzy to be a
powerful wizard if that isn't an
indicator of his level of power then I
don't know what is 3. Aleister Moody
considered by many to be the most famous
Aura of all time Alistair Moody was a
very impressive wizard Moody joined the
order during the first Wizarding war and
is said to be personally responsible for
a very large portion of the witches and
wizards in Azkaban this earned him quite
the reputation amongst the dark wizard
Community Moody was a truly impressive
dark wizard Catcher And Warrior he would
do whatever it took to win and Moody
served with great distinction during the
first Wizarding War even losing an eye
leg and knows in battles against the
Death Eaters Moody was incredibly brave
but also extremely powerful particularly
in his prime he was a master of dark
arts defense against the dark arts
dueling charms Transfiguration potions
herbology Apparition flying non-verbal
magic and even occlimency 2. Barty
Crouch Jr body Crouch Jr was a British
pure blood Wizard and the son of
Ministry of magic official while temis
Crouch senior Crouch Jr has a rich
history with the Death Eaters and joined
them in his teenage years Barty Crouch
Jr famously kidnaps in prisons the
powerful Mad Eye Moody then teaches at
Hogwarts School for an entire year in
his stead what's so impressive about
this is that he was completely
undetected even by the powerful
Dumbledore Crouch was powerful in every
area of Magic and was known to be
skilled at dueling potions charms
Transfiguration occlimency nonverbal
magic and more but what made Crouch
truly dangerous was his intelligence
achieving 12 owls during his time at
Hogwarts I think think the Crouch may be
one of the most underrated Wizards in
all of history number one Bellatrix
black Lestrange Bellatrix Lestrange born
Bellatrix black from the house of black
was a frightening pure blood witch that
came from a long line of powerful
witches and wizards with a twisted
agenda Bellatrix is undeniably one of
the most powerful people in The
Wizarding World basically only comes
after Dumbledore Voldemort Grindelwald
and maybe Snape when it comes to raw
power Bellatrix was a known proponent of
the cruciatus curse and had considerable
knowledge in the realm of the dark arts
she was also an expert dualist charms
expert powerful aquamans and tenacious
Warrior yes Bellatrix was defeated by
Molly Weasley but I think it's safe to
say that she just let her ego get the
better of her if she hadn't
underestimated Molly she may still be
around today and that concludes this
list had a my top 10 matchup against
yours did I mess up and miss any obvious
ones that deserved a spot comment down
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live
[Music]